le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
à la réunion le taux de chômage chez les
jeunes était de 44% en 2016 comment
trouver du travail dans ces conditions
le cnps armes est un organisme soutenu
par le département qui propose aux
réunionnais d emploi en métropole et à
l'étranger à 20 ans dorian a décidé de
repousser les frontières et de tenter
l'expérience de la mobilité
[Musique]
aujourd'hui rien n'est venu s'ils
voulaient bien me suivez la matinée
s'annonce chargé aucune arme de saint
pierre dans la salle d'attenté
la tension monte pour ces jeunes
réunionnais ils sont venus passer un
entretien d'embauché pour un emploi en
métropole et se retrouveront dans
quelques instants sous le feu des
questions sur sa vie professionnelle
vous plaît le plus en fait qu'est ce que
vous avez fait pendant ces stages votre
préférence parmi les candidats
dorian et yanis 20 et 23 ans au wat de
jeunes proposé de faire un bts décidé
d'arrêter au bac pro pour me lancer
directement dans la vie active de
restauration ne soit pas fonctionné je
me suis dis qu'il est temps de
pour nous n'en valent au fait je vais
rentrer dans une vie professionnelle
plus pour atteindre cet objectif c'est
de volontaires se sont tournés vers le
cnps armes
cet organisme propose aux réunionnais en
recherche d'emploi des postes en
métropole et à l'étranger une
opportunité pour yanis qui ne supporte
plus les périodes de chômage
je commençais travail j'ai fait un nom
après ça que j'ai travaillé sur trois
mois en espace vert
mais ça n'a pas fonctionné donc ça
recommence et lé chômage
mais après ben je voulais plus
coaché comme ça en fait pour reprendre
leur avenir en main
yanis et d'orient sont entrés au rsma de
saint pierre en fait il y avait des
formations que propose l air et c'est
moi j'avais plusieurs et moi j'ai choisi
de me prendre
agen magasin aiguillé par leurs
formateurs les candidats postulent tôt
aujourd'hui pour un poste de préparateur
de commandes dans des grandes surfaces
en métropole le bureau des postes à
pouvoir signer région lyonnaise d'accord
que vous avez de pose pas pouvoir sur
aix en provence deux postes à pouvoir
sur l'arthrose
l'entreprise de recrutement coréalise
travaille depuis plusieurs années avec
le cnam
cette fois elle a 24 postes à pourvoir
en métropole disposer d'une arme un peu
et un peu d'annoncés valeurs que l'on
recherche un fact de prendre du
personnel qui vraiment très éloigné de
l'enfant il n'y a pas besoin d'être
expérimenté pour qu'on les prenne un
diplôme inférieur sont des contrats de
professionnalisation qui durera en
moyenne donc après ça dépend des profits
les plus beaux sites des entreprises
adhérentes sur un an
en général ils font tous leur contrat
ils se prennent tous leur diplôme c'est
très très rare le coup d'épinglé
d'hirson apprenons que sont plutôt
motivé consciencieux investi parce que
c'est un changement important c'est pas
de calais légère je vous remercie
chacune malgré un changement que vont
connaître des dizaines de réunionnais
cette année
est-ce que c'est clair pour vous votre
départ quelles que soient vos raisons
parmi eux on retrouve d'orient il a été
retenu suite à son entretien ne rien
donc que je te lèves présentée par
guillaume
aujourd'hui ils participent à un atelier
pour préparer son voyage donc le savoir
être 4 c'est pourquoi je pense par leurs
trop de soldes
ouais l'apprentissage de quoi ça peut
être d'autre que ce qui est important là
c'est qu'ils puissent prendre confiance
déjà d'un de leurs connaissances leurs
compétences et de leur valeur c'est à
dire qu'à sont les points forts mais
qu'est ce qu'ils vont pouvoir mettre en
argent est bien dans leur nouvelle vie
en métropole dans leur donner des armes
va dire au niveau professionnel mais
aussi sur l'environnement au niveau
personne que là vous avez partir tarde
pas à les commenter le cordon ain des
conseils plus que bienvenu pour dorian
le jeune homme n'est jamais allé en
métropole mais la peur de l'inconnu
n'entame pas sa détermination à sauter
le pas j'ai dit que c'est une belle
occasion fait aller en métropole
le fait qu'on ait
on est suivie une époque seuls et
trouver du travail en métropole va
découvrir d'autres choses est
indépendant j'ai détaché de ses parents
à burnaby tout ça me disent que c'est
une bonne chose c'est une belle occasion
ils sont par contre sont quoi justement
et pour rassurer candidats et par an le
kn armes assure un accompagnement et un
suivi des jeunes expatriés de
l'accompagnement l'accueil de réunion
métropole est un point fondamental de
récits de la mobilité de ces jeunes
parce que s'ils vont les baisses livrés
à eux mêmes beaucoup n'ont jamais voyagé
et puis c passable donc il est normal
que dans notre mission globale
cette fonction d'appel d'accompagnement
soit la meilleure possible pour que les
gens ne se sentent sont pas démunis et
surtout parce que nous avons aussi
besoin de faire un point sur leur
recherche d'emploi potion l'état
d'avancement de leur contrat de travail
de la période d'essai est aussi à terme
précédemment une meilleure traçabilité
de ce qu'ils viennent d'orient a
désormais toutes les cartes en main il
devrait s'envoler vers une nouvelle vie
au début du mois d'octobre
le kn armes est un organisme qui propose
aux réunionnais d emploi en métropole et
à l'étranger pour postuler à ces offres
il faut être âgé de plus de 18 ans et
être demandeur d'emploi le kn arme peut
aussi prendre en charge le biais
d'avions
il propose entre autres une aide à
l'hébergement une prime d'installation
et des indemnités pendant la durée des
contrats en alternance pour plus
d'informations vous pouvez vous rendre
sur le site du cnam au www.cnil.fr
[Musique]